hello everyone and welcome to a really
wild game that was played yesterday
on hikaru stream between hikaru nakamura
and french grandmaster jewel moussar
and it's uh quite the game it really
shows how very dangerous
it is and how very good things can
happen at the same time if you break
basic opening principles uh so without
further ado let's
check it out uh as hikaru opens with e4
we have c5 by mozart ah sorry about that
we have knight to c3 so the sicilian is
on the board we have uh the start of a
closed sicilian but
after d6 we have knight to e2 and now
a6 but hikaru just transposes with the
d4
uh into a normal sicilian captures
captures and now knight f6
we have the night of sicilian uh bishop
to e3
the english attack uh we have knight
beat to d7 and now
g4 so this is all very standard stuff uh
preparing uh h4 g5 and so on at
charge at black's king side uh h6
preventing g5 and now h4 hikaru wants to
get that
g5 in uh so black continues with b5 and
this is all perfectly fine black
black of course wants to get his bishop
to this long diagonal
and this has all been played before and
here unknown moves are
uh a4 uh that's uh that's an old move in
this position but the move
uh that uh hikaru plays bishop to g2 is
not a known move so as of move nine we
have a completely new game
so let's see what happens here knight's
the e5 blocking the e5 pawn a because if
e5 comes could be very dangerous will
come with a double attack here so knight
to the e5
and excellent central light square for
black's knight and here hikaru just goes
forward with the pawn pushing so g5
threatening the knight here we have
captures captures and now
black trades rooks we have captures
captures and now
you need to do something about this
knight so knight after g4 and these are
now
very very uh nicely placed knights uh we
have bishop back to c1 hikaru doesn't
want to allow this trade knight for
bishop so bishop goes back
uh and the reason why you go back here
if you go to d2 then you no longer
have a defense of your knight and also
if the knight comes to c4 your b2 pawn
will be under attack so
uh the bishop is actually perfectly fine
on c1
uh and here uh there are uh
different ways you could continue this
game queen to b6 seems to be the nicest
one
but black immediately goes for b4 and
this is where fun things start to happen
hikaru goes back
knight c to e2 and now uh while black
could continue in
in a lot of ways he goes knights to c4
and this is already
uh very greedy as uh well uh even
unless it's not uh winning or unless
you're getting some sort of an advantage
or something
uh playing so much with your nice or as
we like to call it on this channel too
much horsing around
uh breaks opening principles and you
might get a get a difficult position
uh here hikaru played f3 but actually
you could take advantage of this
position right away
uh with the move e5 now e5 doesn't win
any rooks here because black can just
move the rook
but or or play d5 but the point is white
now has e6 and now black's position is
just terrible
it doesn't matter what you captured upon
with bishop or knight
bishop or pawn queen to d3 and now queen
to g6 is coming
and black will have very hard time
surviving this even if
knight the e5 guarding both the g6
square and attacking the queen
you can just attack this knight and next
move you're just gonna play f3 and win
the knight on g4 there's nothing black
can do about this
but of course this is a three-minute
blitz game so of course players don't
have all that much time to
spot anything i just wanted to point out
that good things can happen
uh when one of the players breaks
opening principles and unless it's not
punished then good things will happen
for the player who breaks them so
ricardo goes f3 here
kicks away the knight from g4 knight g
to e5
now uh and here b3 uh trying to get away
uh
trying to kick away the other knight f4
also is very interesting here
uh just attacking that knight and after
the knight moves then you can again go
e5
with an attack on the rook and here
again
uh very hard to say what black could
play if black can move the rook if black
can even trade once and then move the
rook
but still e6 is coming followed by queen
to the three queen g6 and it's a very
very
uh difficult position for black but okay
hikaru goes b3 here
uh he waits with with this e5 idea
uh knight back to b6 and now comes
bishop to e3
uh that english bishop goes back to e3
we have bishop to b7 and now
uh a4 uh well f4 was also a possibility
and then you start pushing those pawns
so a4 uh and here
rook the c8 black finally gets that
brook into the game he wants to play
queen c7 put some pressure
along the c file a5 by hikaru further
dislodging this knight
knight back to d7 and now queen to d2
now hikaru goes after that b for pawn
and black happily gives it up we have e6
now uh if if queen captures uh the queen
might come
in in some line of attack of this bishop
but hikaru says it's not a problem just
queen captures on b4
for the moment this is not possible
because the bishop on b7 is hanging so
queen to c7
defending it and now uh as the well the
c2 pawn is under attack uh
not not right away because the uh white
knight defends it but that can
change very quickly so just queen back
to d2 you wanna
uh get that queen away and also as long
as the queen is now here and the bishop
is defended now the pawn
can actually move and the bishop will be
attacking the queen so queen back to d2
and now black continues with d5 so
very interestingly it's already moved 22
and neither player has castle so
this is a very very a very sharp game
hikaru
finally goes for that f4 move kicking
back the knight
knight to g4 and now e captures on d5
and
what do you play here uh here the
problem is if you trade for example
bishop captures captures and captures
after
hikaru castles it's uh uh very hard to
play this
with black he's down a pawn and he
doesn't really have uh
all that many active moves and the white
will just uh
well white will just continue uh pushing
pawns and enjoying his position so here
after he captures on the e5 we have
bishop to b4 now with an attack on the
king and the queen
uh problem is the bishop is not defended
here mossad
wants to get the queen away from the
defense of the e3 bishop to grab it here
so here queen captures on b4 with knight
captures on e3
but now uh there is something mussar
missed and now it's a completely winning
position for white
so feel free to pause the video and win
this position for hikaru while i give
you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting the
idea there are many moves that win here
like
c4 is winning d captures on e6 is
winning but
e6 uh whoever found that is the quickest
way to win and congratulations to
everyone who found it
uh and uh now there's uh nothing for
black to do here because you have to
keep an eye on the bishop here
uh but there's uh there's no good way to
do it so here black tries a trick black
plays queen captures on c2
uh but now there's uh
there's uh nothing for whites to do here
unless white
actually makes the mistake of capturing
the queen and allows this captures with
check here black would be fine for
example king the one knight captures on
b4
and even after bishop captures here rook
to b8
now white white could even go for rook
to c1 because you cannot capture the
bishop
uh because of this checkmate but you
could just
temporarily give up a piece and then
after white captures you're going to
capture here
you've prevented a white from reaching
the seventh rank and
now it's uh uh e and an equalish game
why it could be a little bit better but
uh nothing to worry about uh but instead
after this queen captures on c2 hikaru
just said uh thank you for the bishop
and played queen captures and b7 and now
black is down uh
black is down a piece and without much
counter play all of the squares uh to
harass the white king are covered
there's not much you can do here
and rook to c1 is coming so here queen
to c5 was played
but it doesn't help black all that much
hikaru just played uh
the quickest winning move here and that
is b4
and now uh there's nothing more for for
the black queen to do on the c file and
he was in this position that
joule mossar resigned the game as there
is nothing more to be done here the
queen has to move
and you have to keep an eye on the rook
and c8 so there's no good square for
example if you move the queen somewhere
queen to
c3 or something uh doesn't really matter
like
even if you if you even if you uh place
the queen on c2
you don't even have to capture it you
can just play anything you you can play
rook to c1
it's still winning you could have gone
bishop to c6 still winning
so any move wins here so it's a
pointless to even continue this with
white and even
after even if you give up some material
captures captures and captures which
check
uh black is still getting checkmated
there's nothing for you to do you don't
have access to the c8 square
and once you move the rook wherever
doesn't really matter just queen to c8
checkmate or
you know uh if you move it anywhere
along uh
the c file there really aren't any good
moves uh there's
nothing nothing to be done here uh king
captures and while the game can continue
it's really pointless you get the idea
i just want i just want to try and
illustrate how pointless it would be
so yeah after b4 uh massage resigned and
an excellent victory for hikaru
and uh yeah it was really funny uh
this whole this whole horsing around
thing uh
we will see this very often of course
especially in blizz gamers especially in
three plus zero blitz games
that one player will break computing
principles like this and then you have
to
remain calm and try to spot the absolute
quickest way to
defeat your opponent uh or but also you
have to you know watch your time so
uh that's that's uh the fun of chess you
can never
you can never be right whatever you do
but yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it thanks for suggesting it
uh i would like to thank frank combs ola
carlson eric hansen phil johnston
and sydney wayne simon for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank all for
watching
and i will see you soon continuing the
morphe saga checking up on your
wonderful suggestions uh
and the tata steel chess tournament
starts in two days so
thank y'all i will see you soon and have
an excellent rest of your day